[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is the amazing
interesting deep spiritual teacher
Michael Beckwith Michael's a meditation
teacher he's a conference speaker and he
is a seminar leader for the life
visioning process he's also been on
Oprah he has three books he became very
famous for his work on the show called
The Secret talking about
manifestation and the law of attraction
so I've been following him forever for
those who don't know I actually watched
a secret back in 2008 like pretty like
very close to when it came out and then
I went and won in Japan right after that
so I always kept that connected we just
had a really cool conversation about
life and how it works and how energy
works and how manifestation works and
how you know the forces that keep us
down and the and what we need to embody
and feel so that we can create the
reality that we want and also outside of
us what is that reality what is reality
and he is really good at this stuff and
he's really brilliant we got a little
bit into extraterrestrials we got into
other entities go to go to human and
what a what a beautiful message she has
to offer just truly truly enjoyed this
interview it actually just kept getting
more and more fun as it went so I hope
you love it please hit the Subscribe
button and please let me know what you
think in the comments I'm going to start
off by like asking a big question what
is God God is how obviously more than a
concept God is a presence of love beauty
intelligence life itself
that's
that's Omni omnipresence God is
everywhere
omniscient so it's all knowing
and it's omnipotent meaning it's the
only real power this and there's nothing
outside of the infinite everything else
is an experience of our limited
perception so the presence of God is not
a man in the sky it's it's beyond gender
and
uh if you look at the evolution of human
consciousness you'll see Humanity
projecting human qualities onto the
presence God created an earthquake God
created a tsunami God's creating
suffering God has chosen people whatever
the case may be
but as we evolve as a species we come to
an awareness that this presence is
eternal and that we've all emerged from
this presence we didn't create ourself
we emerge from the presence as a
distinct unit of of love and beauty and
intelligence according to our uniqueness
so so another way of saying is God is
life with a capital l that's conscious
of itself pure Consciousness yeah what
could that be like going a layer deeper
it's life it's that what is that what is
life then
life is that which is conscious and
conscious of itself
it has uh so the presence of God is
totally self-conscious it knows itself
um there are different stratas of of um
of life
that are not necessarily totally
self-conscious God is still there
but God becomes conscious of itself
through us through a spiritual being
having a human Incarnation we can become
conscious of ourselves we could become
conscious of our thoughts our emotions
our moods our beliefs our perceptions
all of that is in our field of awareness
and we can become conscious of it but
that which is conscious
that's that's life that's the presence
right there
so when an individual is becoming aware
that something is passing through their
awareness that individual is aware of
the presence of God as their life
you see it's Eternal it's forever never
took a birth will never die
is infinite and will always be on the
edge of Greater expression of its
infinite nature so that that that energy
um is the energy of evolution
you see and it's the energy of
unfoldment explain that more that
Evolution that always expanding
like my deepest biggest question in life
is like what is reality
the guy look around and I'm like are we
holographic are we interested
holographic indeed like I want to know
because what I feel like when I know
what this game is then I'll know how to
play it better
so you have a lot of questions in there
yes that is how my mind works
so when we when we deal with uh
life and life is infinite
no beginning no ending so it and it has
the capacity of expression so it's
always expressing itself
so there's never into it's always
unfolding now there's a difference
between evolution and unfoldment
unfoldment is there's something already
perfect
and it starts to reveal itself for
instance you know analogies are
interesting but they get close so you
have an acorn So within the acorn the
idea of the oak tree already exists and
so the oak tree the acorn doesn't create
an oak tree
through unfoldment the oak the acorn
reveals through unfoldment that there's
an oak tree there
you see so it didn't create it it's not
causing it it's revealing it when it's
in the right condition
so evolution is what happens to
different structures based on external
conditions so we can say that you know
there's an evolution of certain species
it got too cold and so they developed
fur it got too hot they lost their fur
or whatever the case may be but the idea
of that species the idea of a of a human
being of a spiritual being having a
human Incarnation there's a perfect idea
of us
that when the conditions are right it
unfolds it reveals itself
So when you say what is what is the game
what is reality reality with a capital r
is that love and beauty in life
they exist everywhere
but we must be the vibrational condition
for it to reveal itself through us or if
not we get caught up in small R reality
which is simply the experience of our
beliefs
we experience our beliefs whether they
be true or not
you know I used to do a a a practical
joke years ago when I was in college I
don't know why we call them practical
jokes they're not practical but
we would take a book of matches
and uh we would go up to one of the fell
our fellow students and we light the
match blow it out and then quickly touch
the person with a cold match
they're thinking we're touching them
with a hot match and suddenly they form
a blister a heat blister on their hand
and they get upset a little bit we said
no we touched you with a cold match
follow me then we go to the next person
lighter match blow it out touching with
a cold match they get a blister more
often than not
so they were having an experience of
their belief they weren't having an
experience of that which which reality
cold match
they were experiencing their belief
so humanity is experiencing a belief in
separation
not enoughness lack limitation they're
experiencing that they're experiencing a
reality that's not real
it's why we call it the world of
appearances
because things that appear to be real
are simply thought forms that we're
experiencing
but it's in the um the background of God
love beauty intelligence eternal life
which is never touched by experience
what is the role of the illusions that
we experience the
anything other than love and connection
and
God frequency energy God Consciousness
Christ Consciousness whatever you want
to call it what's the role of it
well it gives us feedback as to what
what we are attached to in our
Consciousness now let me break that down
just take the word problem as an example
like people have a problem now the word
problem comes from the word emblem
so a problem is emblematic of what's in
our awareness okay so if we're attached
to a particular thought form or
perception a belief an interpretation of
a past experience then that becomes
emblematic as an issue in our life so it
gives us feedback we're getting feedback
as to what is in our awareness
so if we keep repeating something over
and over and over again there's a belief
that probably has an emotion attached to
it it probably has a um the vanity of
the ego saying mine as I said in other
words that's my opinion that's my
thought that's my belief
which creates a you know attachment
then all of that shows up as experience
but it's feedback we're getting we're
getting feedback all the time
so that small reality is is is you say
what's this role it's giving us feedback
we're actually having a direct
experience of our belief even if the
belief is unconscious
it leads me to a question that I've
asked a few different people but it's
about objective reality and it's about
being able to really see anything other
than ourself
so what are your thoughts that come to
mind basically I'm wondering how is it
possible that there is something can I
see things objectively and then that's
actually a second question as to whether
or not I'm ever really clearly seeing
you or if I'm only seeing myself
you're seeing yourself and you're seeing
what you think of what the thought you
have of me okay so um
yeah it's still yours so I don't like I
don't see your thoughts I don't actually
see you
objectively no you see you see
accumulation of beliefs thoughts
perceptions opinions
projected onto me
some of it might be accurate some of it
might be inaccurate last January
I was about to do a podcast
or a class I can't remember but I always
sit down I'm like I always meditate
before I pretty much do anything and so
when I opened my eyes I was blind I
couldn't see I was I was engulfed by
white light
and the it was so powerful it was like
thousands of searchlights those big
searchlights I was in it so I called
Reverend Kathleen McNamara and Lee Brown
I said I can't do the interview right
now or the class I'm blind I can't see
and uh so I'm sitting there I'm in Bliss
now there's not there's no fear It Was
Fear for a minute
but then I just relaxed into it it was
just
I'm getting to this point um so
after a moment I could see
I was in this light but I could also see
outside for lack of a better word and
Kathleen and Lee were standing next to
the door
and I looked at them and what I could
see was a filament of light
in their being was like a fountain it's
a fountain of light
and I realized that that's who they were
they were light
they were light the the body Temple was
um
encapsulating this light so
for so I was giving the privilege at
that moment of seeing
who they really were they weren't their
bodies
they weren't uh their past experiences
they were light they were light
and that wasn't the first time I had
that experience was the first time I
ever had it publicly with other people
around it was never it was always um in
my house meditating or something going
on of that nature and so when you say
so we see
our beliefs
projected onto the screen of life
and I'll tell you a story
I meant this is many years ago
it's probably over 30 years ago
I was about to teach a class I was
teaching a class
and a young lady came up to me and said
that there was a a man in the class that
was kind of harassing her not not
sexually but just bothering her saying
negative things and things like this and
she told me who he was
so I I said to myself okay well I'll
keep an eye out for this
so I'm in class
and I'm looking at the guy
and I start to form this opinion wow
she's right he is kind of negative he is
kind of abrupt
blah blah blah
so I go to her and I say I see what
you're talking about and I say the guy's
name she said no not that guy another
guy I was looking at the wrong guy
but based on which he planted in my mind
I started to project it onto him and I
started to see it
it just it just really gave me a very
powerful lesson yeah about projection
and it gave me a powerful lesson about
taking other people's thoughts
and and and owning it and projecting it
onto the world it was it was very
powerful
so it totally goes that that's basically
the when we change the things we see
change absolutely
yeah that was when Wayne Dyer's favorite
quotes you know how do we grow from from
from seeing ourselves through someone
else so first off it's to know that
we're seeing ourself in someone else
right so how do we grow from that and
then what are the ways that we can turn
inside internally and what are the sort
of like modalities or techniques that we
can use to grow and learn about
ourselves by looking inward
so when we when we are what you're
describing projecting parts of ourself
onto someone else we have to take
responsibility and own that you know so
so total responsibility is one of the
first ways of growing and then you have
to say Okay what is this that I am
projecting projecting is it um a lack of
self-love and appreciation is it Lack of
self spiritual self-esteem you know what
what is it that I'm placing on to this
other being so when I take
responsibility for it now I can become
still and I can allow to float up the
actual belief or thought that's
generating that projection now that
belief or thought is a lie it's not the
truth it's a lie anything that's less
than God less than intelligence and a
beauty and life is it's a lie because
we're Spiritual Beings emerging from the
Eternal so anything unlike that is a lie
that we're telling ourselves how do we
discern then
like how do we know what's a lie versus
like is that is it just if anything is
not positive or is it I think it's not
life-affirming is a lie
when we hear that thought it's not
life-affirming that it's not it's not
the truth it might be an experience
we're having
but it's not the truth of our being
a lie believed acts as a law until
neutralized
any lie that we have that's running us
it will become our personal law we can
we can change States we can change
relationships we can change jobs
but that lie will run us and it will act
as our personal law until we neutralize
it look within we see the LIE we
dismantle it
through prayer through meditation
through forgiveness
until it's no longer operating within us
now we become free and we see life
differently we see people differently
there's less judgmentalism
you know uh with this less projection
but it you know it doesn't it it takes a
degree of um
radical sincerity and inner work
it's real sincere wanting to wake up and
not just because once you have a
projection you put it on the world
the ego then says it fights to say I'm
right yeah yeah I'm right about this
and that's one of the ways that we slow
ourselves down because we Embrace I'm
right
they're wrong look for it and then you
look for it right if you have an idea
that you know
um guys always cheat on me then you go
and look for it right or if you have an
idea that the world treats me terribly
you actually go out and I'm only just
I'm like speaking from experience like
if you go out into your life and you
actually look for look to justify yes
belief and you'll find it and you also
helping to create a condition for that
to show up right explain that more
because that's the tricky one yeah so we
live in a field of infinite potential
infinite possibilities but the
possibilities can only come in a
manifestation if the condition is right
you know you can have a you could have a
seed the seed has the potential to be
whatever olive tree apple tree but it's
not going to do that unless the
condition is right it has to be planted
it has to have the proper soil Sunshine
water when the condition is right it
shows up so that's true about anything
uh if if if you're holding a seed
thought whether it's the sea thought is
affirmative
or whether the seed thought is not
you if you create the condition that
thought will emerge so if you're looking
uh for what would you say somebody
cheating what's the other things yeah or
like the world is uh the world the
world's a bad place then what you're
looking for you're looking with
you're looking with that Dynamic so
you're also helping to create the
condition for that
with vibrational beings so Reviving at
the condition of what we are afraid of
what we cherish what we love yeah you
see so
the bad news is that oftentimes what we
are afraid of has more emotional impact
you know the the the the universal law
says
you don't get what you want you get what
you're interested in
so if you're looking around for
negativity
then you study of the condition to have
that experience if you're looking around
for that which is affirmative and
life-giving then you you'll be getting
to Trend in that direction it's all
lawful no no none of it's personal
you know if if you fall off a building
and you hit the ground and go Splat
break your arm or something it's not
it's not personal gravity is not
personal you know to you oh you know I'm
gonna get her you know no you took her
one soften the blow right you know it
works either way you know it's not going
to just suspend itself yeah you know so
so we learn to you know own our
projections
begin to have an awareness that we're
actually surrounded uh Einstein once
said you know the question we have to
ask is the universe friendly
you know uh he he figured that it was
the friendly the universe was friendly
it was not working against us I like to
use the word Progressive it's it's the
universe is Progressive it's not working
against us
so we have to be in alignment with it
and then wonderful things occur because
we're in alignment not because we're
good people you know and we're better
than anyone a weird alignment
you know if somebody is a gymnast and
they learn how to be in alignment with
their body and how to do certain poses
and things you know they're not better
than anyone they're just in alignment
with that particular skill
so in the same way we learn to be in
alignment with Our intention we learn to
be in alignment with spiritual practice
and then our personal Law changes for me
I always figure I always feel that
everything's I just have an awareness
everything's always going to turn out
okay I don't have any other thought even
in the midst of challenge
that's just my inner feeling so it you
know if it hasn't turned out okay it's
not over over I totally I'm with you
how do we get into alignment you know I
have my own experiences with this but
what is the quickest way because then I
also will add that I'm not sure we
always know what's best for us or even
extremely really even who we are to some
degree so we can't it's not I don't
think we just know right so how do we
get into alignment with the energy
that's actually true
and then what are the signs that we're
in alignment now most people don't know
because individuals have been imprinted
from the time they were in embryo with
uh the social milieu whatever is
happening in society whatever's
happening in our parents home you know
so our one thing and what we think we
want is not really coming many times not
coming from our soul essentially coming
from society right you know so when we
ask for what we want we don't even know
if we really want it you know what I
mean I was counseling someone last year
very famous young individual very rich
very famous and uh she had been in and
out of rehab many times and um and she
said to me
she said you know what when I was in my
20s
I wrote down that I wanted to be rich
and famous
see the very next week
I I got a lead in a series been working
ever since
she said I have not had one happy day
since and now this person's close to 60.
you know they could have been and out of
drugs bad relationships but they thought
they knew what they wanted
rich and famous
they got it
and they have not had one day of
Happiness now they're starting to
because they're coming into a spiritual
awareness so you're right most people
don't know what they want they're
getting a lesson in that then if you can
ask for something and get it somebody
did ask yeah
you want to infuse that with certain
qualities okay I want to be I want to be
full of joy I want happiness I want
peace of mind I want a deep sense of
well-being uh you know these so whatever
you get you want to be in that soup
physical emotional qualities yeah yes to
to and to imagine instead of the exact
thing
just
visualizing and feeling and embodying
the way you want to feel that's it right
there and then let the universe deliver
how you're gonna get that feeling
because that's essentially all you
really are looking for absolutely it
will create the condition
to match that feeling harmonizing
Prosperity really great friendships good
support system health of the body Temple
that will all come
because you're putting first things
first
you know there's an old statement that
says hell is God giving you everything
you want yeah yeah
because you're immature I mean I mean do
you want what your six-year-old want it
you know do you right and it goes back
to do you really know what you want
right right no are you mature enough to
even be able to ask for the right thing
right so you encapsulate everything with
a with a quality
qualities of love and joy and happiness
and in peace you say what you want
and then you always add this or
something better
so you love the universe to be able to
maneuver it so that you're not stuck
with your limited wanting my friend
um my dear friend NADA she gave me this
little Mantra to say when things are a
little awry and she goes I just stop and
I ask the universe how can it get any
better
I didn't get any better
I should do talks on that all the time
that's the question you ask how can it
get any better can this get better and
you do that even if things are really
good it's true it's true you're totally
right you're exactly right and uh it's
amazing I mean you most you notice it
the most when there's the most contrast
right but it's like you just can't
believe that the Universe lined up
something so magically that you're like
you can do nothing but believe in the
power of saying those those words and
how can it get better than this I'm
gonna get better than this
I'm infinite look at this
every potentiality available is right
here absolutely
um so then what are the signs that
you're in alignment because again if
you're not always sure you just sort of
ask for the feeling you want when do you
go okay wow stay on course yes this is
right even if maybe something hasn't
fully materialized or come to fruition
what are those Winks from the universe
that are the the are saying yes well in
the Manifest world they're um obviously
their Serendipity is a coincidences that
occur that you did not plan
that just show up opportunities that
that pop up that show up you beat the
right person at the right time you
realize oh something's happening here
and then there's no then you start to
have an awareness that you have less and
less anxiety and anxiousness and a
greater sense of peace
and that greater sense of peace is not
tied in to an external event it's like
sometimes you know why am I so happy
why do I have so much peace because
nothing seems to has changed in the
external world
but I'm feeling a greater sense of
happiness and joy and peace
that means you're coming more in harmony
with your intrinsic nature it has
nothing to do with the external world
and now as I said earlier conditions
will start to shape-shift
in order to give birth so you can give
birth
to your highest desire your soul desire
your heart's desire
what is your understanding of dimensions
and timelines
because
it feels like right we choose a
different reality for ourselves and we
literally get onto another track of of
Life essentially they're infinite
Dimensions you know dimensions are
vibratory planes got it Earth plane
which is composes of three dimensions
you go to the fourth dimension Fifth
Dimension there are different different
dimensions this is what Jesus meant when
he said in my father's house are many
mansions today he would say in this
unified field of awareness there are
many dimensions you know and I go to a a
high dimension and I'm waiting for y'all
you know I'm paraphrasing but so yeah
there are many dimensions that we have
access to and the average person is
dimensionally challenged
they only live in three I mean
why would you just want to live in three
dimensions but materialists have a have
a tendency to live in only three you
know uh someone that may call that might
call themselves an atheist might be
living in three maybe not there are many
atheists that embrace the qualities of
love and peace so they live in higher
Dimensions even they don't believe in
God you know so there are many many
dimensions in the idea
is to be able to
bring those dimensions and that
frequency to Earth
in the old theology it was dying and go
to heaven the new theology is I'm
bringing Heaven to Earth yeah I'm
expanding my awareness while I'm here
and I'm bringing it here I'm not going
to die except to my littleness
and so I can be in heaven now I can be
in the higher frequencies now and then
bring it to Earth
so the old theology is dying even though
it's still loud and and clangy and and
uh there's still a lot of Believers at
that level but more and more people are
escaping into an understanding that wow
Heaven's right here my own awareness
it's right here
has it always been that way though
always
it's always nothing's changed
what's hell then hell is a state of
consciousness of mainly stagnation
refusing to grow so Heaven the word
Heaven is a Greek word that means ever
expanding good that's what heaven
actually really yeah oh wow and hell is
stagnation
I'm I'm not growing
I'm stuck so if a person a person puts
himself in hell if they're stuck in
resentments animosities unforgiveness
hate
you know and they refuse
you know a chip is too heavy to carry
you know uh a grudge is too heavy to
carry you know but that's hell
the person is stagnating so Heaven is
expansion
hell is stagnation the states of
Consciousness so they're not places
even though they're vibratory places
it's not like you know a person can be
in Hell on Earth what are some of the
universal laws that are the most
important to understand because you
talked about our own laws that we create
essentially what are those outside of us
that are universal laws that we could
benefit from based on linguistic
convenience everybody knows about the
law of attraction that's a very basic
law you know as you become in tune with
a certain feeling a certain vibratory
imaginal Realm you bring that into your
experience
[Music]
it's really the next law it's really the
law of resonance
you're actually like a tuning fork if
somebody hits a tuning fork everything
in that frequency would start to vibrate
so when you start to resonate with the
dynamic of abundance Prosperity love
peace those qualities you become a you
become a everyone resonates everyone
generates a field you start to generate
a field so there's a law of resonance
that that we come in harmony with that
happens when people are chanting they're
singing they're praying you know
um they can somebody can like go in
their garden and they just kind of fall
in love with the flowers or they fall in
love with their dog or whatever the case
may be there's a there's a level of
residence then there's a law of
emergence
meaning that at a certain point that
which is within you begins to emerge it
begins to show up
a butterfly emerging from a caterpillar
caterpillar is already there the
imaginal cells are already in existence
within the caterpillar when the
condition is right the the butterfly
emerges
so there are qualities within us gifts
genius capacities within us
and we're not really attracting them
that's why I said the Law of Attraction
we use that word as linguistic
convenience to to help people just
understand sure but really what's
happening is
you are
coming into that vibration
so that that which is here can emerge
from you
because if you stay with I'm going to
attract something to me you're saying to
yourself I don't have it
but I'm gonna get it it's gonna one day
come so you end up putting your good in
the future so when I start to come into
resonance
you see
um it's it's different you know there's
I'm I'm I'm in Residence so so you know
so I'm not saying that a vision board
doesn't work you can look at stuff and
start to feel you start to feel this is
what Prosperity feels like
and then you sustain that so this is the
feeling so so it's getting into the
feeling the visceral
body feeling might arise emotions you
might breathe heavier you might cry you
might smile spontaneously yeah something
where you actually get into you actually
become it yes the feeling provides the
healing
and then there's emergence where then it
emerges from you you see now the issue
is many people
they do it on a hit and miss basis
or they dabble
um
because I'll ask people do you meditate
yeah do you do this yes do you do this
yes
and then I'll say what consistently and
they'll say well you know I kind of
dabble I go when I'm in emergency when
it's emergency I'll do it you know but
if you move from dabbling
and curiosity to a level of dedication
you start to see greater results it's so
interesting I'm I would guess I'd have
to say I'm a little bit of a dabbler I
use spirituality spiritual sort of
modalities on an as needed basis is it
possible almost feel so blessed that you
don't even know what to ask for yes
you just stay in the feeling and then um
that Grant the feeling of gratitude
maybe maybe you can relate to this
sometimes parents would say to their
kids
if you don't stop crying I'm gonna give
you something to cry about
sure you ever heard that statement yeah
yeah okay so the universe says if you
don't stop being grateful I'm gonna give
you something to be grateful for
so if you hang out in gratitude even if
you don't know what you want you can
hang out in gratitude then the universe
brings you something
in that vibration instead it shocks and
surprises you
because you you weren't really
you want that specific about X Y or Z
but suddenly something adorable okay
that's good I like that yeah so
gratitude and that higher frequency
really really helps you be in alignment
with the law of receiving
receptivity availability the greatest
availability on the planet like to the
greatest abilities on the planet is
availability you know how I'm available
am I am am I am I
to the total givingness of the spirit
how available am I you see and so there
used to be a belief that it was IQ that
determines a person's success
now we know there doesn't you know
Harvard did a 30-year study took the
highest IQ people entering the Harvard
and other colleges and then mapped them
for 30 years and so there was no
correlation between high IQ and
happiness health or success there's no
correlation you know but there was
something I what I call availability
quotient when you're available there's a
you use the word surrender earlier
you're surrendering to something higher
you're yielding it doesn't matter what
your IQ is your availability quotient
and your just your your your
gratitude you're hanging in possibility
thinking
provides the context the vibrational
context for more good to flow into your
life
you see and so it's not IQ it's AQ what
blocks us from things because of the
dimension of time well let's let's go
two two ways at this one there's
something called involution and there's
something called evolution involution is
the planting of the seed evolution is
the evolution of that seed to become
what it's supposed to be and in three
dimensions that takes time
you know it takes time for an acorn yeah
years and years and years to finally
become a mature oak tree okay now
at The Meta level at the um non-dual uh
non-linear level there's no such thing
as time time doesn't exist
time is a mental construct right see
um
time is the measurement of distance so
where are you right now what part of the
world are you in Arizona okay so in
Arizona so there's distance between us
physically
so it would take me a certain amount of
time to get to you if I walked if I
drove a car if I if I was on a plane
we'd measure that you know it's going to
take this amount of time to get to her
you know so it's the measurement of
distance and it's the measurement of
duration of a thought
so if I'm having a thought and the
thought has captured me I'll have an
experience of that thought let's say you
imagine a snake is coming into your room
right now it's not a snake it's just a
rope but you imagine it's a snake and
you're nervous and you're anxious oh my
God and for the next 10 minutes the
duration of that thought until somebody
says it's just a rope
oh okay now in reality there's no
distance between us because we're both
emerging from the center of the universe
okay and the moment that thought stops
that experience stops so time is not
real it's an abstract concept that is
used in this Dimension to measure
Evolution you ask the question you know
what is it that we don't know about time
or how we how do we use it incorrectly
by putting our good in the future
we'll say
my ship is going to come in it's going
to happen one day
you see but we have to feel and act as
if it's already happening yeah so
somebody would say you know what would
you do if you're prosperous oh you know
I would be very generous or whatever
okay be generous now
but I don't have any money I'm not
talking about money
be generous with your time your thought
your compliments you know you can't you
can't give a hundred dollars give a
dollar you know
but load within your generosity the
feeling of having because here's the
other law it's it's stated in the Bible
it's a beautiful law it says to he or
she who has or is given
and to hear she who has not even that
which they have shall be taken away
it's not personal
so if you walk around feeling that you
have
more is given if you walk around feeling
that you have not then that which you
have is taken away
so what do you do you put yourself in a
position of being a giver even if you
have little
even if you have little you still
consider yourself a giver this is why I
tell people you know if they want to be
more prosperous
you know when you get paid or however
you get your money
put a little bit aside that you don't
spin just start saving for yourself oh
that's that's going to take too long I
can only save ten dollars a week it
doesn't matter
every time your mind looks at what you
have
it'll start to the law will start to
become I have
I have ten dollars I have twenty dollars
I have fifty dollars I have a hundred
dollars I have I have I have until your
your inner frequency starts changing
from I don't have yeah to I do have and
then more is given opportunities start
to open up
because you're feeling that you are a
hammer
the opportunities start to open up that
brings more Prosperity more
opportunities for prosperity in your
life so you don't put it into the future
now
because we're just energy it's just
vibrating and we're just matching why
why is that so hard for people to grasp
well people are in the conundrum of The
Human Experience they're they're daily
under assault by their own minds that's
been hijacked by fear
and then they are addicted to the fear
because of the toxic chemicals that go
through the body Temple there are people
that actually are addicted to the news
start there's a chemical that's releases
cortisol it's release you know it it it
it debilitates the immune system it
stops you from thinking coherently you
get you enter into fight and flight it
messes up your blood pressure but people
become addicted they think they're alive
I have drama therefore I am you know
there's drama going on there I'm alive
oh
you know so there's a great addiction
it's called fear porn is society guilty
for perpetuating more of those things
happening because thoughts become things
the average person is just ignorant but
there are nefarious forces that want you
to buy things you don't need that
manipulate
so that there's greater fear or greater
sense of Doubt or a greater sense of
lack of self-worth unless you're wearing
this kind of perfume driving this kind
of car taking these kind of drugs to
alleviate your anxiety you know so
people use the power okay influence it's
called malicious hypnotism it's what
it's called
um they they they become Adept at
malicious hypnotism so that there's
certain levels of angst that people live
in
and when there's a certain level of
angst people are more easily controlled
their mind is more easily hijacked so we
actually have to take back our mind you
said nefarious so now I'm gonna have to
go down that rabbit hole I'm gonna go
like wacky out there a little bit like
nefarious so I feel like people are good
to me in my experience we're programmed
by our environment however there's also
belief that there are truly like evil
nefarious people perhaps even other
entities like controlling human beings
So when you say nefarious how far does
this go or where does this go beyond
humans
well when I met in the first I met
people that were so blind to themselves
they operate out of greed okay
stinginess manipulation control might
makes right there are people that live
like that and they're so cut adrift
from their from who they are that their
choice and decisions are totally ego
based it's not we it's a total I I'm
going to profit from this I'm going to
be successful I'm going to control you
know so this is so it's the fairies in
that sense in terms of outside of the
human uh species of course there were
beings to think otherwise would be
foolish you know I mean when you look at
now the new telescope that just came out
and you see trillions of galaxies you
know that exist you know the
somebody would be silly to think that
the Earth plane is the only plane where
there is life it's just silliness it's
just you know so of course there are
other beings and they're all developed
at different levels there's certain
beings that are very highly developed
but they're underdeveloped emotionally
and so when they're doing things they
have no idea they're hurting people it's
not it's not a part of their they
haven't evolved at that level yet so if
in fact they begin to experiment on
somebody or it's you know things like
that they're not even in touch with the
fact that they might be scaring or
hurting that person so it's not like I
want to scare and hurt this person it's
like I don't it's like a sociopath it
doesn't have the capacity right so there
are beings out there I wouldn't call
them sociopathic but it's unevolved at
that level
you know we have people on the planet
Earth that are very empathetic
you know they don't want to cause pain
they don't want to feel pain they're
very emotionally mature
so to speak you see so yeah there's all
kinds of beings beings um that exist out
there and uh and some absolutely inter
interface with Humanity interface with
our government and things of that
particular nature I mean I mean I know
you know I I know this like for a fact
in terms of people that I've worked with
you know so it's not like how does that
show up then how does that show up like
when you say you know well I I well I
don't generally talk about this you know
for instance I knew I know a guy he's
passed over now he worked with many
presidents of the United States many of
them
his mother was a human being his father
was not
and yet he was extraordinary man he did
so much to keep people safe on this
planet and the country safe
and he had to deal with forces that
weren't necessarily operating for the
highest and best of all concern you know
I know this guy I I met him through some
other people and sometimes when things
were happening on the planet
that were very terrible or about to be
terrible they him and his people had to
intervene he would call us together one
two three o'clock in the morning we'd
have to go into meditation in prayer wow
the whole Space yeah used a bomb or they
did this or why they did that you know
and I was privileged to this kind of
thing
and
he would say to me if you ever see me in
public don't speak to me just pretend
you don't know me you know and that was
years ago he's gone on but that's that
that's one thing you know I've had other
experiences and I've had friends who've
had other experiences with these with
other beings the Western world is so
censored
it's so censored the media is so
censored people just are ignorant about
the things that are so very in front of
our face so I would tell the human
beings every now and then just look up
I interviewed John Paul De jorya a few
years ago now back when my podcast first
started and
um he started Paul Mitchell and Patron
and super successful entrepreneur he
told me during this interview it was not
anything that I was expecting
um based on talking to an entrepreneur
at his of his level
um but we got into aliens and
extraterrestrials and
artifacts and things of that nature and
he said this is in 19 this was summer of
19. he said within five years we will
know that extraterrestrials are real and
it is 2023 yeah and we've had all this
stuff just go on recently with shooting
down craft and these Rando balloons and
whatever's going on so is this the time
I think even more than that I think
besides those balloons people are seeing
sightings all over the United States all
over the world of these um crafts that
can stop and go stop and go up and down
and and uh I was in Arizona here last
week last week there was one where there
was like a a streak in the sky and it
was sort of like more a little bit
vertical horizontal like line and I
thought it was just some weird cloud
like I remember looking at me like
that's weird and I look I'm like I don't
know maybe it's some kind of like it was
a plane or something like that anyway
then all of a sudden it shows up on the
news like what is this in the sky like
when they say when people like you know
love Neil deGrasse Tyson I I think he's
amazing I think he's interesting and
smart but like when someone like him
says like but where's the proof I'm like
I don't know everywhere like what do you
mean the proof like there's so many
videos and accounts and pictures and so
much there's so much for years for years
I have a a friend that was um in this
service and he was on the uh ship during
the storm and he would see they would
see these um
different crafts hovering all the time
and they were they were sworn I said you
can't you know they were they were told
you can't tell anybody what you see you
know but it's people like Neil deGrasse
who's that their intellect is so high
but in order to really go to the next
level you have to suspend the intellect
to go into your intuition direct knowing
and a lot of those people can't do that
they're they're inhibited by their
intelligence isn't that interesting
if they can't smell it and taste it and
touch it and hear it you know it doesn't
exist so they are uh hindered Yeah by
living only in three dimensions yeah you
know so so they they think they're not
hindered but they're in the world of
Academia
you know in the world of Academia has
never healed anything
and it's linear right you have to go get
it right like it's just you know when
you get in tune with
get an alignment now you flip that
vertical and you're in alignment with
all potentiality absolutely but that
doesn't make sense to a linear person
what about
crystal children
you know benevolent beings coming
through humans is there are there or
like the first wave of volunteers second
wave of volunteers you know whatever
name we give them
you know everything is evolving so the
Earth is vibrating
at a at a at a rate that's never
vibrated before it's it's worth is very
conscious so when you when you talk
about
um the different crystalline children or
whatever the they're matching what's
happening on the planet as well so
there's a there's an evolution that's
happening with Mother Earth so the
babies that are being born are actually
matching the next frequency of the
planet you know so you go back a number
of years ago people were heavy
materialists
spirituality then burst onto the scene I
mean not that it wasn't always here by
certain avatars and and followers but
you know early 80s it went to another
level and now
this conversation that we're having
right now this would have been really 30
years ago yes now it's accepted now it's
accepted it's a woo to some people yeah
but you know it's accepted because the
evolution of Consciousness has happened
so yeah those beings exist they're
matching the frequency of the earth I
see that makes perfect sense that those
waves come in as the frequency of the
planet shifts and that is what's
anchored with the new children so how do
you take into like what do you account
for or what are the beings that are so
much more evolved you know such as
yourself and have such great or such a
greater awareness
and you know there have been all
throughout history I mean Jesus Christ
you know um the Buddha Krishna like how
do you account for these these these
very special individuals that defy the
frequency of the planet
well there's there's no special beings
that they're just beings who specialize
so
so just like there's no one born pretty
much unless they are a savant you know
from another lifetime play the piano
they practice practice practice practice
practice practice practice
until noise becomes music until the
music plays them so we say oh he's
special she's special no they
specialized ours
until they had that Genius of being able
to play the piano so when you look at
the Buddha with this practice of
meditation
[Music]
not you know every day every day every
day long periods of time he specialized
in taking his attention away from the
world until he woke up yeah you look at
Jesus
fasting 40 days 40 nights you know
fighting off his ego which was called
Satan fighting off his ego coming to an
understanding that man is not meant to
live by bread alone but rather every
word that proceedeth out of the mouth of
God
now we know if the guy doesn't have a
mouth so he's living directly from the
field of awareness he's heard directly
from the field you see
um you study all these people they had a
certain level of devotion sincerity in
practice
that opened them up to see in reality
now it can be argued
they probably did a lot of work in a
previous lifetime
maybe maybe not
the difference between Jesus and Buddha
supposedly according to my friend who's
passed over now David Hawkins is that um
Buddha
Brooke got off the will of reincarnation
after many lifetimes he awoke
Jesus did it in one lifetime
in One Singular lifetime he became aware
of his Oneness with God what was that
not without dedication you know practice
now with all the teachings that he said
how to do it go into your inner closet
God reward you openly forgive 70 times 7
make it a way of life you know if you
all he gave you the blueprint you know
and then Christianity came and just kind
of smothered it but but the teachings
are very powerful so all these big
Krishna oh my God
yeah
totally have a total Avatar total awake
you know
um
like Jesus I think arrived on the planet
that way you know and uh
so there's a lot to say about what
happens even before you get here
explain that we have pre-incarnational
choices meaning when you are about to
take a human Incarnation you didn't you
didn't get pushed to take one you chose
an Incarnation and in choosing that
Incarnation you also chose you know what
you wanted to contribute while you were
here what you wanted to learn while you
were here and so whether a person is a
savant
or or not a person has chosen to be here
to go through
whatever this experience is in order to
make their contribution in order to hone
their gift in order to
um forgive their past in order for them
to wake up
sometimes people get caught
in the sludge why they came here until
so they wake up and say oh this is why I
was here oh they hear a voice they see a
podcast they read a book yeah what I've
been doing what I've been doing with my
life well we're talking about sort of
like recognizing your Oneness but
that feels like second phase first phase
being what usually feels like almost
like a spontaneous Awakening is that how
it normally goes but many people have
that and don't don't do anything with it
oh this becomes a memory
really it's like you can't come back
from that you can't come back from that
you can't come back in that feeling it's
like this and Beyond but sometimes
people put themselves back to sleep
too much
did they choose that
it was too much for them Free Will is
involved they didn't have a it's totally
involved they didn't have um you call
yourself a dabbler but I can tell you a
little bit more than that
if you have if you have a Satori moment
today
Satori suddenly you just see more than
you've ever seen before yeah you're not
gonna go back to sleep with that because
you have some level of understanding and
some level of practice you're going to
fan that fire you see now somebody
that's just not awake doesn't have any
spiritual practice
it could go two ways they can say oh my
God I gotta find out what this is that's
what happened to me yeah I had to
discover what happened what happened you
know it changed my whole my whole life
changed and I know other people who just
became a memory it's still theirs it's
bothering them but they're not doing
anything about it environment fear some
people are the light is so bright on the
ego that the ego will put up roadblocks
and distractions to keep you from
exploring it further because the ego
does not know the difference between
Enlightenment and annihilation
that sucks it doesn't know the
difference
all it knows either way it's not going
to be running the show
the ego doesn't know the difference
between Enlightenment and Annihilation
that should scare the crap out of
everyone well it definitely scares the
crap out of the ego when you start to
feel that you're an eternal being then
the only thing you're ever losing is
your limitations you know you're not you
don't ever lose anything when you
surrender what does that feel like to
you feels like
everything is always going my way even
when it appears to be not
it's just that's how it feels it feels
like
like life is good
it's not a life it's free it challenges
I'm not saying that
you know there are challenges in the
human dimension on every level
but I live in a space of all is well
and everything's unfolding perfectly why
is that space
that I I I'm asking asking to describe
so ineffable like you can't you use the
word
it's so like my experiences that I've
had like I can visualize it and I can
give you the words it's almost like a
dream where you can go okay I'm gonna
tell you what happened but it's not
conveying what I experienced so why is
it that they that that when you get into
those I'm gonna call them higher higher
Dimensions
um higher frequency why can't we
articulate it here you can because in
words you can only say what it's not
because the word can't say what it is
because the words obscure it
you see it can take you to the precipice
of it
through the power of inspiration
but it can only say what it's not
because what it is is so once you say
what it is it ain't that because you
said it yes you've named it and that can
only be that and that's not what it is
it's everything right that's what the
bhagavad-gita says water wets it not
fire burns and not wind blows it not
away if you name it you can't find it
and when you find it you can't name it
that's straight out of the bhagavad-gita
and you find it you can't name it it's
just uh I had a teacher that used to say
um there's a there's a school of fish
swimming in the ocean
and then this big wave pops went up onto
the beach
and the fish for the first time is seen
people play volleyball at beach ball and
they've seen a picnic and his snoke has
no context for what he's saying and then
the wave knocks him back into the water
and all the fishes what do you see and
all I could say was Era or uh or uh you
couldn't say anything else because he
had no context to Define what he had
seen so everyone has an era experience
like or a
this is what happened I can it's not
this it's not this it's not this
to the best of our ability we try to
describe it
but then it sounds often times like
some romantic
big thing you know because compared to
like just ordinary Consciousness it is
you know but then people think it's far
away but it's not is God
trying to show us
the truth or what we could be or how we
could feel or is it God in us we are God
and we are getting glimpses when we
dissolve the veil and talk enough to go
yeah Bliss you enter into Bliss States
when uh the veil is cleaned and suddenly
you're in bliss bliss is different from
pleasure pleasure goes up and down it
has its issues but bliss doesn't have
any side effects
you see it's it's that's what happens
when I teach that you enter into the
door of enlightenment
by realizing you're already enlightened
all you're doing is removing
the obscurations from the mind
you are it you're it yeah you and you
didn't create yourself
you emerged from it as it
emerged from it as it gets so so the ego
can't grab your it and say well I'm it
and she's not
we're all it
and it don't forget what is the point of
this what is the point of there's so
many different kind of levels here but
even just this Human Experience like
let's just take each and each and every
one of our individual human lives that
exist right now what's
the purpose of it every I believe
everyone has the same purpose we have
different missions different ways of
expressing purpose
but our purpose is to reflect and to
reveal
the face of the Divine according to our
duty pattern that's why we are here to
do that that somebody may do that as a
choreographer or a teacher or whatever
but you're here to do that now when we
look back billions of years
and we bump into what is called the Big
Bang or the moment in which that which
was invisible became visible as
Cosmos
multi-dimensional Universal Solar
Systems galaxies living biology et
cetera et cetera et cetera
people used to think they used to tell
Parables well God was lonely
so God
birthed all of this out of itself so
that God would be lonely now we know
that's not true
how do you know that because you can be
alone and not be lonely loneliness is a
fog of the mind it's not because there
are people who can be with people who
are lonely and people will be by
themselves who are lonely but there are
people who can be alone
and not be lonely
so what it so that emergence was not
from loneliness that emergence was
emergence from Bliss
the presence is so full of bliss and joy
it burst in into creation
so that the trees and the flowers and
the grass and everything in existence
would be in gratitude to be able to
participate in the realm of the Divine
and the presence could know itself
through all of its creation it could see
itself through all of its creation know
itself as a blade of brass know itself
as a human being becoming conscious know
itself as any of them billions of beings
all throughout the multi-dimensional
galaxies
the presence is to be in Bliss and know
itself is all of that it's fun
it is it's like I am so grateful to get
to the point where every now and again I
can feel that Bliss or joy as I've
called it just by like looking at a tree
or a cactus or something very simple
it's not something found in some deep
Yoga Retreat on a 3 A.M pineal gland
meditation it's like walking the dogs
you know and I wish I could get that
more often but it's
um it's really beautiful when those
little things happen so yeah little pin
Pricks of reality breaking in yeah
well thank you so much wow I mean I
clearly have a lot of questions but I
feel like we have to do it again checked
a lot of boxes right there and you just
uh you really shared such
um valuable information and you know we
can only just hope that we all just keep
raising our level of Consciousness to
really see ourselves as what we truly
are
that's the game yeah thank you Michael
thank you for the invitation thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button